When Matthew Cuthbert reached the station, there was no sign of any train.
The only person he could see was a young girl, who seemed to be waiting for someone.
"I'm not expecting a girl," said Matthew.
"I'm expecting a boy."
"There must be a mistake," the station master said.
"Mrs. Spencer said that you and your sister were adopting that girl from a children's home."
When Marilla saw Matthew at the door with the little girl,...
...she said, "Matthew Cuthbert, who's that?"
"Where is the boy?"
"There wasn't any boy," said Matthew.
"There was only her."
"No boy? But there must have been a boy," said Marilla.
"We told Mrs. Spencer to bring a boy."
The little girl heard this and cried out,...
..."You don't want me!"
"You don't want me because I'm not a boy!"
"Nobody wants me."
"Oh, what shall I do?"...
...And she began to cry.
Marilla said to Matthew later,...
..."This girl will have to be sent back to the children's home."
"Yes, I suppose so," said Matthew sadly.
"But she is a really nice little child, Marilla."
"It's a pity to send her back when she wants to stay here."
When Anne woke up the next morning, she could not remember where she was.
Then, she remembered.
This was Green Gables and they didn't want her because she wasn't a boy!
It was such a beautiful place.
She wished they would not send her away.